the first week of the new year is
traditionally when hospitals are at
their busiest but kovid is putting them
under exceptional pressure
almost 25 000 people are now in hospital
in england with a virus
far exceeding the peak of the first wave
and there's far worse to come
the hospital admissions of today are the
new diagnoses of a fortnight ago
so go back to just before christmas and
the rolling
seven day average of new cases was just
over 34
by the end of december it had soared to
49
500 a rise of 44
now that spike is being driven by the
new more easily transmissible variant of
the virus
london was one of the first and worst
areas affected
the infection rate rose steeply through
december
reaching 900 for every 100 000 people
there are signs that the rate of
increase has leveled
off and that started just as the tier 4
restrictions came in
but the controls haven't brought cases
down and without turning the screws
even harder hospitals would still be
overwhelmed
in parts of the country such as tier
three liverpool
rates have still been rising hence the
pressure
for tougher nationwide control of the
virus
across the country rates are highest in
secondary school-aged children
around three percent according to the
office for national statistics
rates in primary school children are a
little lower around two percent
there is evidence that children have
been bringing the virus home
and in the current context public health
trumped
education this has been a grim start to
the new year
and those vaccines can't come soon
enough